momento de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América en France 24 Jorge
bienvenido qué tal Rosa Jorge empezamos
hablando de un debate que se ha
estancado en Europa no como avanzábamos
al inicio de este programa y se trata de
encontrar un enfoque común para regular
el mercado energético en el bloque de
comunitario bueno Francia y Alemania
lideraron esta discusión en torno a la
energía nuclear los ministros de energía
debían alcanzar una posición común sobre
esta reforma que tiene objetivos tan
amplios como más energía limpia
asequible seguridad del suministro y
también nuevas inversiones pero la
negociación fracasó cuando París y
Berlín discutían sobre cómo los
contratos estatales con el generador
fijan un precio de compraventa de
electricidad en un plazo y luego este
dinero se devuelve la diferencia esto en
función de que si el precio real fue más
alto o más bajo que el que se había
estipulado esa discusión se centra En
que si este término debe aplicarse a los
operadores existentes una medida que
permitiría por ejemplo a Francia
subvencionar muy fácilmente su parque
nuclear Francia dice que la energía
nuclear es clave para la transición
energética y que debe ser reconocida
junto con el resto de energías
renovables Pero hay países como Alemania
y otros que lean que esos subsidios a la
energía nuclear podrían dirigirse Más
bien a la energía eólica solar y otras
fuentes renovables el debate seguir en
los próximos días pero escuchemos que
decía al término de la reunión Teresa
Rivera vicepresidente también ministra
para la transición ecológica de España
que deberíamos incorporar como buena
práctica el respeto a los acuerdos
alcanzados y no reabrir de nuevo estos
asuntos y hace apenas tres semanas hubo
un estado miembro que solicitó el
recapacitar en relación con un punto
concreto
se ha propuesto por parte de la
presidencia sueca y por parte de la
comisión la inclusión a una referencia
en este en este preámbulo de la de la
directiva y
no yo creo que es que es importante
poder cerrar este acuerdo cuanto antes
porque cambiemos de tema dejemos de lado
esta posición tan polémica que ASUME
siempre Francia respecto a la energía
nuclear y por otro lado Es que hoy se ha
negociado la mayor adquisición de
aviones de la historia de qué se trata
Bueno lo consiguió airbus con la venta
de 500 aviones a índigo que es la mayor
aerolínea de India ejecutivos de ambas
compañías anunciaron este acuerdo en la
inauguración del salón aeronáutico de
París la aerolínea dominante en India
comprará aviones a 320 pero no brindaron
detalles del monto de este histórico
acuerdo el récord anterior de la mayor
compra de aviones en la historia sucedió
en febrero de este año también cuando
otra compañía de India ordenó 470
aviones airbus y Boeing actualmente
indio tiene una cuota de Mercado ahí en
India del 61% en el sector de
aeronáutica y espera duplicar su tamaño
expandirse también Asia central para
finales de esta década recientemente
India superó China como la nación más
poblada del mundo y aprovecha la
creciente demanda de viajes por parte de
los consumidores de clase media para
expandir su negocio bueno Jorge y
curiosos no interesados para conocer
finalmente este monto cuando cuando se
haga público y cambiamos de información
porque Reino Unido está renegociándonos
sus mercados sus tratados comerciales y
ha anunciado nuevos tratos
preferenciales con 65 países pobres y en
vías de desarrollo Así es bueno esta
medida también Busca reemplazar otros
acuerdos similares que tenía cuando era
miembro de la Unión Europea si el
anuncio lo hizo el ministro británico de
comercio internacional Nigga Hudson
según su cartera Este régimen elimina o
reduce los aranceles y hace más sencilla
las normas comerciales el régimen
beneficiará a 65 países con una
población de 3.300 millones de
habitantes eso es más de la mitad de los
cuales se encuentran en África e incluso
asegura que este nuevo régimen es más
generoso que los previos al brexit según
reino el acuerdo ahorrará a sus empresas
unos 948 millones de dólares al año
gracias a la reducción o a la
eliminación de aranceles sobre
importaciones por valor de más de 11.500
millones de dólares en productos como
ropa alimentos y juguetes para niños
bueno veremos y Jorge venimos ahora con
información de América Latina porque se
disparó la inflación en Venezuela por
primera vez desde enero si los precios
al consumo allí subieron un 5,1% mensual
en mayo según los datos del Banco
Central los mayores incrementos de este
índice los aportaron Los costos de las
comunicaciones que subieron un 13,1%
intermensual mientras que la salud el
precio de la salud aumentó un 7,5%
también mensual según la información
oficial la inflación acumulada en 5
meses de este año fue de
96,3% con la variación de mayo la
inflación interanual se ubicó en
429,2% o según los cálculos de routers
que están en las cifras del emisor
venezolano que de por sí es la más alta
de toda la región la economía se ha
ralentizado en Venezuela en los últimos
meses tras los escándalos de corrupción
en la industria petrolera su mayor
fuente de ingresos extranjeros el
gobierno de maduro recurrió a la
impresión de dinero para compensar el
crecimiento económico pero lo que hizo
fue alimentar la inflación y debilitó
aún más su moneda pero maduro culpa a
las sanciones de Estados Unidos de esta
crisis económica bueno Jorge Y supongo
que la inflación en Venezuela no es la
cifra que más le ha llamado la atención
en el día de hoy Cuál es la cifra del
día entonces la cifra del día es 1500
millones de dólares eso prometieron los
donantes para su dan según asuntos
humanitarios de la ONU esto tras la
reunión de representantes de Egipto
Arabia Saudita la Unión Europea la unión
africana también Alemania Qatar y otros
países que están reunidos en ginebra
para discutir la ayuda a Sudán en Sudán
la guerra deja más de 2000 muertos Según
a cled y más de 2 millones de
desplazados y refugiados según Naciones
Unidas Jorge Pues cerramos Así esta
Crónica de economía pero nos vemos con
más información económica en una hora
Así será Y ustedes sigan con nosotros
Porque a continuación viene el debate
con María Clara calle
[Música]